次はその同じ偈の逆ですね
ムフッテ マピチェ ヴィンニュー パンディタン パイ ルーパ アサティー キッパン ダンマン ヴィジャナーティ ジッワスーパ ラサン ヤター
ムフッタンっていうのは瞬間でも
ヴィンニュー 理性のある人がパンディタン
賢者をと付き合うならば
キッパン ダンマン ヴィジャナーティ
真理をすぐわかりますよと
理解しますよと たとえ話はジッワスーパ ラサン ヤター
料理の味は舌ならわかりますよと
匙はわかりません だから愚か者は料理の中に入れている匙に例えて
智慧のある人が舌に例えて
料理は美味しいかまずいかというのは舌が決めるでしょうに
舌には大量に食えなくちゃわからないんですかね
味見るためにはほんのちょこっとでしょ
舐めただけで味がわかるんです
で 理性ある人はそんなもんやと
まあこれのエピソードはあまりないんですけど
あの 大体お釈迦様時代でかなりの坊さんたちがね
随分簡単に悟り開いてしまっちゃったんだから
これすごく苦労しているお坊さんたちから見ればね
かなり羨ましいでしょう
ものすごく羨ましがるんですよ
何のことなくさっさと理解しているっていうことがわかると
まあそういうケースがありまして
まあそれはもう理性ある人はね
舌が味をわかるような感じで
瞬間にわかりますよということの偈なんですね
まあそちらで言いたがっている 2つの偈を合わせると
この場合はダンマ 真理のこと
悟りのことを言ってますよ
悟りということは この無知な理性のない人にとっては一生踏ん張っても
まあご苦労様と 理性ある人だったらたちまちと
ということを言いたがっているのです
だから いい店で理性を買っちゃえばいいんです
100円ショップじゃなくて
理性っていうのは まあやっぱりもう買うものじゃないんだからね
まあちょっとややこしいんですけど
ヴィンニュー 理性なんですね
この聞くっていうことは
ただヘッドホンしてるより聞いてるっていう意味じゃないんだ
理性 だから理性だから
だからわしは前説明したでしょ
聞きながら処理するっていうことだからね
しかしこれ主観で妄想で感情でやっちゃうと最悪
自分の主観で自分の好みで
だから最初からそんなのは理性のある人は捨てるんだよと
伝統 日本の文化ではとかね
そんなのはもう理性ないって意味なんです
みんなそういうもの 何かハンディ持ってるでしょ
日本の文化ではそんなことはないんだぞとかね
アメリカではそんなことはできませんよとかね
何考えてるんでしょうかと
アメリカであろうが日本であろうが
もう真理は真理だからしょうがないでしょうに
自由な心で 感情がなく
妄想がなく 主観がなく
客観的に聞かなくちゃいけない
だから頭の中で妄想がざーっと暴れ回って渦巻いているんだから
理性はゼロなんです 理性はないんです
妄想というのは あるパターンで頭ずっと空回りしていることでしょ
心は止めてもらわないと
この概念空回りすることが
それが極限的な理性なんです
妄想やめることは  [背景音楽]頭でいっぱい言葉もものすごく欲張ったりすると
もう考えることもできなくなっちゃう
喋ることもできなくなっちゃうんです
理解することは全くできなくなるんです
頭はいつでも静かで 置いておくんです
静かで 概念何もなく 自分という気分はなくいるんですよ
そうすると人が話を聞いた瞬間で
いきなりもう動き出すんですから
頭が 動き出してすぐすーっとそのデータを処理するんです
それが理性ということなんです
だから妄想 皆様にずっと言ってるのは妄想の話ですからね
無知の証拠は妄想なんです
何か妄想してると言ってることわからないでしょ
もう聞いてないのは当たり前でしょ
妄想しながら聞いたとしても
理解する余裕がないでしょ
頭の中で理解する余裕ないということは
理性ゼロということなんです
理性ゼロだったらもう失格っていうことなんです
明確に だから踏ん張って妄想をやめた方が身の安全というか
役には立ちます はい そんなもんで
えーと まあ妄想 概念 観念
主観 伝統 の肩書などなどをね
忘れちゃえば それが聞く耳ってことなんです
これで認めるかないかではないんですよ
それも覚えておいてください
聞く耳持ってるということはちゃんと理解して
はぁ わかりました その通りしますということではないんです
これは別なことで だから前の順番の途中で私はやめてましたけど
いうのはね まず聞いて
その処理して それから自分の知恵にしてね
それから自分で 4番目にステージで
これは自分が認めるかないかということ
それからなんです  自分の知恵にはなりました
しかし 自分の生き方にこれを入れるかないかということ
いわゆる自分にとって役に立つか立たないかということ
次にやるんです ブッダはブッダの話について語ってますから
そういう順番になりますね
どうせブッダの話ならもう役に立つ
やらなくちゃいけないということになります
自分が今どんな変な性格の人であっても
もうしょうがない 今理解したものを大量なことを理解したんだから
これが自分には役に立つ
だから受け入れなくちゃいけないんだと
しかし 今まで別の生き方をしていたんだからね
そう素直には受け入れられません
あるほど理解しているのに
抜群の理性のある人はものすごい抜群に理解して
もう自分のまず聞く 同時に処理する
それからきちっと意味を感させて自分の知恵にする
3番目 自分の知恵にしたところで受け入れるかないかという決断をする
やっぱり役に立ちます
人格向上します これなら
だから受け入れなくちゃと思っても
そう素直には受け入れられません
心は そこまで進んでないでしょ
みんななんか素直に受けるつもりだと思ってるでしょうに
だからうまくいかないんです
素直じゃない 心は 簡単に変わりません
真理だと知っていても
一般的な無常やとわかっていてもという抑止力もあるでしょうに
そんなもんですよ 頭では無常っていうことはわかりますけど
やっぱり心はそう簡単に素直に受け入れることはしません
だから自分がやっぱりこれは人格に受け入れなくちゃと思ったところで
精進というものが立ち
かなり努力しないと わかって納得して理解している真理を自分の性格に心に入れるために
そこでパダハティ ワーヤマティという 2つの単語を仏教で使ってます
パダハティっていうのは精進する
ワーヤマティっていうのは徹底的に踏ん張って頑張っていると
それでそうパダハント
ワーヤマント そのように精進努力すると
真理は自分の体験になって
自分で自分が経験したことになります
それは悟ったっていうことなんです
お釈迦様の話 さんざん聞くと
一切無常やということまではいきますよ
次のステップ それは自分に役に立つか立たないか
自分が受け入れるかないかという決断しない
まず 決断したところで
あ それ素直には受け入れられないんだと
今までの自分の人格から見ると
そこで踏ん張って強引に受け入れてプログラムを書き換えなくちゃいけない
書き換えたところで自分そのものなんです
無常もブッダの教えも全部
それはもうとっくに悟っているんです
そういう順番なんですね
仏教の学問は 俗世間の学問については興味ないんだから役に立ちませんだからあまり言ってないんです
しかし これは完璧な学問方法だから
一部一部パクっちゃえば
もうセッティング 俗世間はうまくいくんです
お釈迦様は随分簡単に
サッダージャートダンマンスナーディスッタダンマンダレーティダターナンダンマナアッタンウパウパリッカティアッタンウパリッカト
ディティンジャナンカマティディティンジャナンカント
なんか言葉狩り忘れちゃった
とにかくワーヤマティですね
ワーヤマティ ワーヤマント
もうその難しいパーリ語単語
もう昔覚えたもんだからもう忘れてます
で カーエーネチェダンマンスッチカロティというところで我々も経験するんだよと
中部経典にあります そこは
今言ったところは そういう順番で学ぶ順番なんです
学ぶ順番というのはもう悟る順番でもあります
聞く 聞くことから始まります
ですから それは声聞乗だと言っておけば大丈夫です
ちゃんと階級をかけていることはできます
声聞乗から大乗仏教は枝成してますけど
大乗仏教はみんな声聞乗なんですけど
誰かさんの話聞いてやってますけど
面白いんですよ 例えば大乗仏教の唯識理論ではね
唯識理論でお釈迦様おっしゃってないんだからね
誰かの作品ですから 哲学はね
これはバスバンとか誰かさんにね
天国のいるメルクボサスが教えたんだと
結局どれだ声聞乗でしょ
その人も なんでブッダの歴史的な事実であるブッダの話を聞く人は軽視するんですかね
天国の誰かさんから聞いたと言った途端
怪しいのは当たり前でしょうに
ブッダがあえて私が自分で頑張って発見したものになると
だから責任持ってます
お釈迦様は はい それで話は一応この辺で終了いたします
えっと それほど難しい芸ではないので
仏教の真理を語るところではございません
一応聞く耳だけ持って[笑い]その方が頭良くなります
聞く耳持ったら ただ単に私は私の話聞けということを言ってるわけじゃなくて
全てのものがいつでも語ってますよ
川も植物も桜の木も電柱も
何でもかんでも存在について
生命について もうずっと語ってますよ
聞いてないだけで 聞く耳を持つと
それを美しく文学的に道元さんが言ってますよ
川も植物も何でもかんでも全部もうブッダ
ブッダの教え語ってますよと
しかし勘違いしないでくださいと
そこを通してブッダの教えを理解するんじゃなくて
それがブッダの声ですよと
そうするとみんなすごい哲学だな
わからないねとかね 川の音こそがブッダの生の声でと言っても
本当は違うんですけど
なんで道元さんがそんなこと言ってるのかと
間違ってますよ 道元さんが言ってることそのままなんです
川の声が真理語ってるんです
ただ聞く耳を持ってないだけで
だから私はすごく嫌がられる
マッセンの方々に なんか私にとってはなんかもう当たり前の
そういう当たり前のことで言うと怒るわけよ
すっごく 親鸞・晩鐘はそのままブッダのブッダであるというと
そんな当たり前のこと面白くないとですよ
あんた方何知ってんのよ
こんなすごい教えとかね
もし挑戦状出したら挑戦受けて立って見せますけどね
知らないのは誰でしょうかと
確かにあの方はね すごく文学的な才能がありまして
美しく語ってますよ そうすると我々の足が文学的な表現に足が引っ張られて中に行かなくなっちゃうんですね
やっぱり聞く耳を持ってないんですよ
だから真理発見したければ
別にキリスト教でも大丈夫ですよ
昨日それ十字架の話を解読したでしょ
それで何のことなく悟りの境地を説明したはずなんです
十字架と受難の話は 微妙に間違ってるところを直すだけ
私は直したのは イエス様だけ十字架に打たれて受難するのでは足りませんと
一人一人が十字架にかかられて受難を受けなくちゃいけないんだと
それだけです 私は入れたのは
基本的に言ってること正しいんだと
全て捨てなさいよと だから聞く耳を持ってるならばね
全て語ってます 真理は
ということで 聞く耳持っているならば
悟りの境地は置いておいても
我々はすごく面白くて
常に智慧が開発する それに面白い世界にいることはできます
アオムシを見てもすごいことを語っています
そこで存在について 生きることについて生きることの意味は何ですか？と私に聞かないで
アオムシ 1匹見ればわかります
生きる意味は 一生懸命葉っぱを休むことなくずっと食べているでしょうに
見たら なんだいい気持ち悪いっていうのはね
聞く耳持ってないだけの話
何が気持ち悪いんですか？言ってる本人です
もっと気持ち悪いのは
アオムシは 0.1ミリグラムもないでしょうね
細胞は 気持ち悪い細胞は
気持ち悪い細胞はもう 60キロ持ってる人は
よく言うこと そこでもう聞く耳が不在ちゃうんですよ
必死になって葉っぱを食べてて
休むことは全くなく 見てください
そちらに全部存在 輪廻のことも
生きる意味が何かあるのかとかね
何のために生きているのかとかね
全部そのまま語ってます
そのまま直接 物語ってるわけじゃないんです
道元さんが言うように
じりじりとそのまま語ってます
青虫を例えにして仏教真理わかるんじゃないんだよと勘違いしないでくださいという感じで言ってます
もっと美しく言ってますけど
向こうは だから青虫がブッダであって
道元さんは青虫のこと書いてないんですけど
もし道元さんが青虫が見たら
青虫がブッダであって
という書くんです それで青虫もブッダではなくて
青虫がブッダですよと
それでブッダと言えば釈迦牟尼如来でしょうとまた書くんです
じゃあ繰り返してみろと
それでわざわざゴチャゴチャ書いてるんじゃないんですよ
本人の修行した経験で発見した世界をタンタンタンタンと随分テンポよく語ってるだけ
本当はあの方もそんな大した勉強してないんですよ
少しちょこちょこちょこちょこちょこと聞いただけのことで
これでものすごく感動しちゃって
で 日本に帰ってきて頑張っちゃうんですよ
だから聞く耳はちゃんと挑戦を
百で聞くんじゃないんですね
そういうことで この我々も普通はね
この聞く耳という言葉でもよろしいし
観察するという単語でもよろしいし
常に何であろうとも区別しないで
差別しないで 主観を捨てて
ただ単に観察しながらいる
そうすると妄想はほとんど消えます
妄想は遮断する それも一つの方法なんですよ
何でも観察すると結構忙しいんですよ
頭は それで観察すればするほどすごく面白くなってくるんですよ
青虫でもじっと観察するとものすごく面白くなってくるんです
そこで青虫を見ていたところで
ちょこっと見たらテントウムシを見ると
全く形全部違うでしょ
それでそれを観察してみる
まるっきり違うんだと
どこかでまるっきり同じっていうこともあります
それを発見すれば それは公園でやるならば
そこら辺で誰かおじさんがじっと座ってそこで寝泊まりしているところ見えるかもしれませんよ
それで見てもらえば ずいぶんテントウムシは違うように見えるでしょう
全く違いますけど 全く似ているところもあります
[背景音楽]しかし 差別主義の気持ちあると寝ている
寝て発見すること正しくないんです
差別ゼロの心で観察しなくちゃいけないんです
区別ゼロっていうところで客観的に
例えばね もう公園におじいさんが毛布を三枚五枚と体を囲って
こうやって座っていて
それでテントウムシは何のことなく背伸びして
あの羽をこうやって伸ばして
ああ気持ちいいなというふうにしていて
全くアプローチ違うでしょ
どう観察されますかね
それは だから空気が寒いか冷えているかあったかいかどうするんですかね
そこでわかるでしょう
アプローチ次第やと空気は空気なんですよ
テントウムシはあったかくなってよかったな
気分がいいなと羽を伸ばす
それは我々手を伸ばすことと同じことだからね
ちょっとストレッチングするんですよ
テントウムシがこうやって
そうするとまた羽を畳むでしょ
中にある羽が中に入りまくってちょっと飛び出しているんでしょ
それまあそれで次にそれも中に入れたりするし
また怠け者はそのままで
もうボロボロ状態でとかね
人間と同じでそれもありますよ
決まって中の柔らかい羽きちんと畳んで
上の硬い羽で締まるやつもいて
まあどうでもいいやだから畳まないということもいて
後で気づいてさっさと中に引っ張るものもいて
それ全然やらない 見ていないでしょ
テントウムシは結局は
面白くないんで そうやって見てみると
そこで何のことなく 人間の世界も同じでしょうしね
で 空気の温度も風の強さも何でも平等なのに
テントウムシにとっては気分が良くて
公園に寝泊まりしているおじいさんにとってはちょっと体が冷えるんだよというね
それでアプローチ次第やと
空気が良くも悪くも何でもないんだよと
自分のアプローチ次第で良くも悪くもなる
同じ空気が だからで好き勝手に変えられませんでしょ？おじいさんにとっては
だからあったかいことにしましょうっていうと
それまた無理でしょ テントウムシはやっぱり寒いことにしましょうと
それまた無理でしょ そこら辺に因果法則見えるはずなんですよ
全てはそういう風に成り立ってるんだろうと
そういうことで そういう何観察したっても
ブッダの真理 そのままじりじりとあるんです
必要なのは見てくださいよだけです
いかに目が見えないのかということでしょ
いかに耳が聞こえてないのかと
信じられない 退屈ってなんとかっていう言葉っていうのはね
[silence]